2023 saw many famous actors take their
final curtain call as well as a few
unsung performers whose legacies you'll
want to know the list of actors who
passed away last year is longer than
would like it to be but their stories
are worth
remembering Lance Cohn spent his
childhood racking up guest roles as
Plucky kids on 70s Fair like police
story Cannon and multiple after school
specials as he grew he starred as
relatable and sensitive team James
Hunter on the drama James at
renamed James at 16 in 1978 playing a
realistic teenager made kwin into real
life Teen Idol in the late 1970s and
early 1980s he parlayed this status into
Parts in the TV movie the boy who drank
too much and the hit Min series
adaptation of Stephen King's Salem's Lot
in which he played lead vampire resistor
Mark Petri it wasn't a
dream Kerwin bounced around TV for years
before largely retiring from acting
after an an appearance in 1995's
outbreak according to his daughter kwin
died on January 24th 2023 in San
Clemente California he was 62 ER Bowen
was a consumate character actor highly
recognizable by his face voice and
demeanor for any number of the nearly
300 projects He was involved with from
the mid1 1970s to the 2010s he was
probably best known for his recurring
role across two decades worth of
Terminator movies in the first three
entries of the Sci-Fi franchise Bowen
played persistent criminal psychologist
Dr Peter Silverman Bowen also co-starred
an Alien Nation 9 to5 and my stepmother
is an alien on the small screen Bowen
enjoyed recurring roles on Mama's Family
scarecrow and Mrs King and Webster he
also had an illustrious career as a
voice actor contributing to animated
projects like Kim Possible the new
Batman adventures Pinky and the Brain
and Cliff of the big red dog on January
6th 2023 TMZ reported that the character
actor had died the previous day in
Hawaii a family friend told variety that
Bowen had recently been diagnosed with
lung cancer he was 81 an art student and
beauty queen screen Legend Gina Lola
Brigida moved into acting in her native
Italy just after World War II this was
an explosively creative era for Italian
Cinema and Lola Bridger was a key part
of it she became a superstar in Europe
and an international sex symbol in the
1950s headlining a run of Hollywood Hits
including the Hunchback of notra Dan
Beat the Devil and Solomon and sheba she
ultimately headed back to Italy where
she starred in wrote and directed a
number of films Lola Bridger didn't act
much after 1973 though she did pop up on
Falcon Crest and the loveboat she filled
her time by becoming a celebrated
photojournalist and a politician in 2022
she ran for a seat in the Italian Senate
according to NPR Lola Bridger had leg
surgery after she broke a thigh bone in
a fall in September 2022 she died in
Rome on January 16th 2023 at the age of
95 Annie woring was a prolific actor
booking roles on dozens of TV shows
throughout the 2000s along with work in
the original The Last of Us video game I
know where he's hiding like Hill you
do old Warehouse in area
5 woring earned particular Acclaim for a
performances as Julia Brasher on B the
Bor Queen on Star Trek Picard and Emma
Whitmore on Timeless she further
distinguished herself by appearing in a
number a fiercely beloved Sci-Fi Action
and fantasy television series her first
ever credit comes from an episode of
Star Trek Enterprise and she later
popped up on series like Angel Charmed
Supernatural and Revolution viewers
might also remember woring from The
Vampire Diaries on which she played
Wicked vampire family matriarch Lily or
24 which saw her portray FBI agent Renee
Walker woring also portray duplicitous
cult leader Leslie Dean on the Marvel
series runaways according to deadline
doctors d noosed woring with cancer in
2020 she died on January 29th 2023 at
the age of 45 in 1977 Adam Rich began a
4-year run as Nicholas the youngest of
the eight Bradford children on Eight Is
Enough Rich went on to enjoy a number of
guest roles and a variety of series
including Silver Spoons Saint elsewhere
the loveboat and the $6 Million Man
tblop role playing game fans might also
remember him from the 1980s dungeon and
Dragons animated series in which he
voiced a magical Presto in the 1990s
celebrated author and publisher Dave
Edgar recruited Rich for a massive prank
Edgar's magazine might reported Rich's
death the victitious memorial tribute
was so convincing genuine news outlets
attempted to jump on the story Rich died
on January 7th 2023 he was 54 Lisa
lauring cemented her Legacy at a very
early age when she portrayed the iconic
and enjoying character of Wednesday
Adams luring was the first actor to ever
play the the somber girl on screen
making her Mark in 1964 The Adams Family
this performance is still making waves
with her frenetic dance with coar Ted
Cassidy becoming a meme in recent years
a breakout child star luring acted only
occasionally after The Adams Family
ended with appearances on the girl from
Uncle Fantasy Island Barnaby Jones and a
long stint on out of World Turns in the
early 1980s her final work came in the
2015 indie horror movie dog to spine
Lauren's friend Lori Jacobson reported
on Facebook that January 25th 2023 the
actor suffered a severe stroke she died
on January 28th at the age of 64 Cindy
Williams was an icon of 1970s
entertainment following some due paying
with commercials and guest swing roles
Williams landed big Parts in major
movies by two of the era's most
important filmmakers she played Lori and
George Lucas's nostalgic blogbuster
American Graffiti and Anne and Francis
Ford copas a conversation a 1975
performance on Happy Days led to
Williams most famous role Shirley feny
Shirley and her friend lne serve as
intimidatingly older dates for the
show's teenage characters their episode
proved so popular that a l and Shirley
spin-off hit the air in 1976 by the 1977
to 1978 season it was the most watched
program on
television I don't vot y do do you vot y
Doo Williams died on January 25th 2023
following a brief illness she was 75
Melinda Dylan kicked off her acting
career in a big Way by earning a Tony
Award nomination for her performance in
the original 1963 production of Edward
alz who's Afraid of Virginia wolf in the
70s she led the cast of three Classics
of the era how Ashby's Woody Guthrie
biopic Bound for Glory hockey comedy
slapshot and Steven Spielberg sci-fi
smash Close Encounters of the Third Kind
however it wasn't until the 1980s that
Dylan landed her most Pyon IC and
enduring role every year millions of
people watch her play the par of
family's doting mother in perennial
holiday favorite A Christmas Story Dylan
followed that era spanning hit with
supporting turns in well received movies
like Harry and the Hendersons Prince of
tights and Magnolia twice nominated for
Academy Awards both for Close Encounters
of the Third Kind and absence of malice
Dylan was a giant of 20th century film
she died on January 9th 2023 at the age
of 83 Charles Kimbro brought an air of
dignified authority to most of the roles
he played across five Decades of acting
he is perhaps most famous for portraying
Jim Dial and Murphy Brown an upright and
uptight veteran anchor a role that
brought Kim brro an Emmy Award
nomination in 1990 in recent decades Kim
brro introduced his deep and serious
voice to the world of cartoons
portraying characters like Victor in
Disney's The Hunchback of notredam and
its spin-offs M Chalk in recess and Dr
to fur on dinosaurs Kim bro's voice also
helped make him a star earlier in his
career he was a two time Tony Award
nominee for his work in big theatrical
Productions on Broadway among many
notable performances Kimbro co-starred
in company kandid and my fair lady Kim
brro also came out of retirement to
apprise the role of Jim Dial on the 2018
Murphy Brown reboot Kim brro died on
January 11th 2023 in Culver City
California he was 86 Raquel Welch was
among the most iconic and glamorous
movie stars of the 20th century she made
a big move into acting in 1966 with the
classic Fantastic Voyage in which he
played a scientist to a shrunken down
and sent into a sick man's body to
investigate his ownness that same year
Welch starred in the prehistoric
Adventure 1 Million Years BC which saw
her Donna fur bikini images of her in
this unique garment became the
Cornerstone of the film's marketing
Blitz and a legendary pinup many vampy
and showy roles followed in the 1960s
and 1970s with bedazzled The Three
Musketeers and Myra Breen Ridge her most
notable recent role came in Legally
blunt in which she played play the Widow
of a wealthy man whose murder is one of
the central points of the film according
to a statement provided by her manager
the actor died on February 15th 2023
following a short period of illness
Welch was 82 in the 1970s and 1980s
Richard beler established himself as a
dark a seric and deeply cynical white
cracker that Outsider stance which saw
him deliver an apologetic social
commentary informed many of B's hosting
gigs and acting roles particularly
detective John Munch bza iated the
katron homicide life on the streets and
went on to portray him on Law and Order
and Law and Order Special Victims Unit
until 2016 he also brought the world
weary drw witted and kingly investigator
to the wire 30 Rock Arrested Development
and Sesame Street B and Munch shared a
cultural background a complicated
attitude about City Life and an interes
in conspiracy theories by bringing him
to such vivid life the actor became a
touchstone to generations of TV Watchers
elza died on February 19th 23 at his
home in France he was 78 you might not
recognize Rico Browning by name but you
definitely know his work in a trio of
films in the 1950s he portrayed the
iconic Gilman aka the creature in
Universal's Creature from the Black
Lagoon revenge of the creature and the
creature walks Among Us highly
proficient in the sort after skill set
of stum performance and underwater
cinematography Browning pulled off
expressive and entirely silent acting
while completely submerged he played the
creature in the movie movies many
underwater scenes some of which are
seriously lengthy Browning continued to
carve out the Nan Hollywood as a Creator
and facilitator of water logged projects
directing the underwater scenes in Kad
Shack and Never Say Never Again as well
as co-creating the friendly dolphin TV
series flipper Browning was part of a
very small Club of actors who portrayed
the titula monsters in Universal's
beloved slew of mid-century horror films
in fact he was the last surviving
original performer of the universal
monsters as they're typically known the
actor and film maker died on February
27th 2023 at his home in Florida he was
93 Lance Ric brought star power and
irresistible energy to a series of
high-profile and cult projects over the
years his intensity and deep character
work often made them Unforgettable reck
broke out on the HBO prison drama Oz
where he played undercover narcotics
officer Johnny basil he then appeared on
the celebrated drama the wire as police
Lieutenant Cedric Daniels reck once
again played a complex authority figure
on Fringe federal agent Philip BRS head
of the titular paranormal office many
more TV roles followed for redic
including deputy chief Irving on Bush
Albert Wesker on Netflix's Resident Evil
spin-off series and deeply evil boss
Christian Deville on Comedy centrals
corporate how good to see you again so
soon Mr Wick shall I announce you film
fans know him best as Chiron the K urge
turn sidekick of the John Wick movies
while Gamers will remember him for years
to come as Commander Zavala of the
Destiny video game series reic was
discovered dead of natural causes in his
home outside Los Angeles on the morning
of March 17th 2023 he was 60 years old
the '90s produced plenty of thoughtful
action movies and Innovative Indies
about the cedia aspects of American life
and Tom seore was often a major part of
that movement after his breakthrough
role as a Vietnam War era soldier on the
TV drama China Beach earned him WID
spread attention seore appeared as a DEA
agent in pointbreak a counterterrorism
expert in passenger of 57 a detective in
True Romance Natural Born Killers and
The Relic and a sergeant in Saving
Private Ryan his career ultimately came
to Encompass more than 200 RS seore
collapsed at his home in Los Angeles on
February 19th 2023 it was soon
determined and suffered a brain aneurysm
he died on March 3rd at the age of 61
filler on the roof wasn't the likeliest
candidate to be a smashit musical based
on schol Mam's beloved tale of Jewish
life and the pale of settlement the
musical tell tells a story of a Milkman
named tavier who struggles to maintain
his Traditions accept his daughter's
potential husbands and navigate a
hostile World Israeli actor Heim toppel
or just toppel as he was usually built
was a big part of the musical success
and would forever be link to the role of
tavier too portrayed tavier in thousands
of stage performances of Fiddler on the
Roof playing the part in the original
1967 West End production revivals in
1983 and 1994 and a Broadway Revival in
1990 most prominently he starred in the
hit 1971 film adaptation which landed
him an Academy Award nomination for best
actor Topol also portrayed Dr Han zarov
in the 1980 movie version of Flash
Gordon and Smuggler Columbo in the James
Bond movie for your eyes only topul who
had been diagnosed with Alzheimer's
disease died in Tel Aviv Israel on March
8th 2023 he was 87 there were three
unique and distinct phases in the life
and career of Robert Blake Blake who
started appearing in films in the late
1930s at the age of 6 between 1939 and
1944 Bobby Blake portrayed Mickey in
more than three dozen hour gang or
Little Rascals theatrical shorts that
gave way to numerous appearances as
Little Beaver in Red Rider movie serials
and appearances on TV Western in the
1950s and 60s after playing convicted
killer Perry Smith in 1967's In Cold
Blood Blake star his detective Tony
Beretta on the TV crime drama Beretta
from 1975 to 1978 which won him an Emmy
Award in the 80s and '90s Blake assumed
a lot of tough guy roles retiring after
a memorably creepy appearance in David
Lynch's Lost Highway in 1997 Blake would
make headlines when he was arrested and
tried for the 2001 murder of his wife
Bonnie Lee bakeley the salacious trial
ended in an acquit the Blake was held
liable in a civil wrongful death suit
and had to pay his the ceas wife's
family $30 million the associated press
reported that Blake died at his Los
Angeles home from heart disease on March
9th 2023 he was 89 Michael Lerner was a
character actor but he retreated into
the scenery a dominant and commanding
force in most every role he took learner
was a quintessential supporting actor
who specialized in portraying
adversarial authority figures and
bullying blowhards after starting out in
San Francisco theater in the 1960s
learner took on many duudes playing
roles on 70s and 80s TV shows including
Hill Street Blues and the Rockford files
and in movies such as Eight Men Out and
Harlem Knights probably his best known
role was as a tyrannical movie studio
boss Jack lipnik in Barton thinkink that
part in the 1992 Cen Brothers cult
classic earned larner and Academy Award
nomination learner worked often through
the '90s co-starring in newses blank
check and in 1998 Godzilla as the
ineffectual mayor of a besieged New York
City later gigs included that of a nasty
children's book publisher in elf and an
anti-mutant senator in X-Men Days of
Future Past Sam learner Michael
learner's nephew broke the news of his
uncle's death on Instagram on April 9th
2023 Michael Lerner was 81 a national
treasure in his home of Australia Barry
Humphrey worked as a comedian actor and
drag performer for decades he's best
known as his drag alter iGo Dame Edna
everage a saucy purplehair older woman
from the Upper Crust who says whatever
is on her mind often speaking truth to
power I counsel and I heal you counsel
and you heal I do a little bit of
healing in addition to portraying D
Edna's odious rival sir Les Patterson
Humphries appeared as a signature
character in hundreds of talk shows TV
series and movies for years day medna
was a virtual regular on The Tonight
Show and hosted the mark talk show Dame
edner Hollywood on NBC in the early
1990s Pixar fans will recognize humre as
a voice of Bruce a shark from Finding
Nemo he also voiced a great Goblin in
Peter Jackson's The Hobbit and expected
Journey humph was so beloved in
Australia that his death was reported to
the public by the country's prime
minister Anthony albanes humre was 89
years old born in Harlem to a family
from the Caribbean Harry bellafante was
America's biggest black multi Hite
Superstar during the mid 20th century in
the 1950s balante was the biggest pop
singer in the United States he sang
traditional and new songs in Caribbean
based Styles including his signature
tune Deo the Banana Boat Song and toed
the billboard album chart for 31 weeks
in the 1950s a singer starred in the
musical movie kmen Jones the romance
Island and the Sun and the
post-apocalyptic the World the Flesh and
the devil after a long break to focus on
the Civil Rights Movement where he was a
prominent and outspoken advocate for
African-American equality and systemic
change working closely with Dr Martin
Luther King Jr bellante returned to
acting in the 1970s appearing in bucken
the preacher and Uptown Saturday night
it final onscreen work was a supporting
role in 2018s Black Clansman balante
died of congestive heart failure at his
home in New York on April 25th 2023 and
96 years old the NFL became nationally
popular in the 1960s thanks to
television and explosive stars like
running back Jim Brown in his 9-year
career Brown was named to nine Pro Bowl
squads never missed a game and set the
records for yards and touchdowns after
leading the Cleveland Browns to its last
League Championship and being named the
NFL's Most Valuable Player in 1965 Brown
decided to apply his talents to acting
his first major film role was in the
classic war movie The Dirty Dozen it'd
go on to star in many more action films
in the 80s and '90s brown did some
episodic TV work appearing on chips
Night Rider and the A Team before poking
fun at his career and tough guy persona
in comedies like I'm going to get you
sucker and Mars Attacks Brown's personal
life was full of controversy he faced
multiple assault char judges in 1968 for
example he allegedly threw a female
partner from a balcony and in 1999 he
was arrested after taking a shovel to
his wife's car and allegedly threatening
to kill her in both cases the women
withdrew their allegations a family
representative told the Associated Press
that Brown died at his home in Los
Angeles on May 18th 2023 age
87 after cutting his teeth with small
rols on British television series in the
1990s Northern Irish actor raced
Stevenson became a prolific go-to guide
for producers all over the world looking
to bring gravity and intensity to their
films and TV series his first prominent
gig came in the 2004 film King Arthur as
a self-sacrificing knight Dagon he
followed that with a run on HBO's Rome a
soldier Titus pul Stevenson then snagged
the starring role in Punisher war zone
portraying the title vigilante in
addition to supporting roles in the
Three Musketeers gi. Joe retaliation and
the Book of Eli Stevenson also appeared
in the first three MCU Thor films as
Thor pal volag as well as in Divergent
as abnegation leader Marcus Eon
Stevenson was heavily involved in the
Star Wars Universe voicing gar Saxon in
multiple projects and playing Bal and
skull in the Disney plus Asoka series
getting to to wield the lightsaber is
just the best feeling in the world he
also played the villainous governor
scottt buckon in the Indian hit ah and
worked alongside martial arts star Scott
Atkins and the accident Man series his
publicist told variety that the actor
died in Italy on May 21st 2023 Stevenson
was 58 years old born Anime Bullock Tina
Turner would become an iconic musician
and earn the nickname the Queen of rock
and roll combining a raspy voice
passionate performance style and
frenetic dance moves Turner propelled
her duo with her then husband Ike Turner
into massive success in the 1960s and
1970s in the 1980s Turner returned to
prominence as a solo act and struck it
even bigger ultimately selling 180
million albums and winning 12 Grammy
Awards Turner was so famous recognizable
and charismatic the Hollywood eventually
beckoned Turner took on just four film
roles but all rememberable she appeared
as the Acid Queen in Tommy made a cameo
in Sergeant Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club
Band Played the villainous ATI entity in
madmax Beyond Thunderdome and appeared
as a mayor and Last Action Hero Turner's
family released a statement to Rolling
Stone on May 24th 202 23 announcing the
Rockstar's death at her home in
Switzerland Turner's passing came after
a lengthy sickness she was 83 years old
starting out in acclaimed films in the
1970s Treat Williams spent the 1980s and
1990s popping up in everything from
Prestige movies to crowd Pleasers to
made for television Fair Williams broke
out with a major role as hippie leader
Burger in the 1979 film adaptation of
the musical hair then appeared in Steven
Spielberg's 1941 and the harrowing
police drama Prince of the City which
earned him a Golden Globe nomination
he'd never be off to scream for long
co-starring in crime sagas such as Once
Upon a Time in America and things to do
in Denver when you're dead over the
course of his prolific career Williams
racked up more than 100 acting credits
and these days he's remembered by many
for numerous Christmas projects for
Hallmark and Netflix as well as playing
dads in Chicago Fire white collar and
chess of be shots what many consider
William's signature role came in the
wb's family drama Everwood where he
started kindly neurosurgeon and
compassionate single father Dr Andy
Brown Williams agent Barry mcferson told
The Hollywood Reporter that the actor
was riding his motorcycle near his home
outside Dorset for month on June 12th
2023 when he was struck by a car after
an airlift to albony Medical Center in
New York for treatment of severe
injuries Williams was pronounced dead at
age 71 across a variety of film genres
and highend Theatrical Productions
Glenda Jackson was among the most
acclaimed actors of both her generation
and the mid mid 20th century a member of
the royal Shakespeare company in the
1960s Jackson portrayed ofilia in a
notable Hamlet staging and originated
the role of Charlotte cord in the London
production of the controversial play
morat sad receiving a Tony nomination
when the work moved to Broadway Jackson
then moved into film with a lead role in
1970s women in love winning her first of
two Academy Awards for Best Actress she
won the other for the 1973 romantic
comedy A Touch of Class more Oscar Noms
arrived for Sunday Bloody Sunday and
header with more tony notices for
strange interlude and McBeth in 1992
Jackson Sidelines are extremely
distinguished acting career for politics
running for and winning a seat in the
UK's House of Commons should go on to
serve as Junior transport Minister for
Prime Minister Tony Blair after retiring
from public service in 2015 Jackson
returned to acting portraying the title
role in a London based King Leah and
winning a Tony Award for three tall
women according to a statement issued by
Jackson's agent and friend LOL Lana the
actor died at her home in London
following a short period of illness
Jackson was 87 Julian Sans brought
intensity and gravitas to more than 150
film and television roles dating back
four decades in the 1980s and 1990s Sans
made a big impression with major roles
in the claimed films such as the Killing
Fields A Room With a View and impromptu
while also starring and scary Fair like
Gothic the Warlock movies and
Arachnophobia you've been
busy incredible Sans also segued into TV
voice acting on Biker Mice from masss
and Jackie Chan Adventures before
starring as ulish on Banshee and
recurring on Smallville as Superman's
father jel in early 2023 just after his
65th birthday Sans went hiking near
Mount baly in California San Gabriel
mountains and didn't return prompting
his family to follow a missing person's
report snowstorms interrupted rescue
efforts until spring on June 24th the
sunburn Dino's Sheriff's Office reported
that hikers had found human remains in
the area where Sans disappeared 3 days
later they were conclusively identified
as those of the actor Alan Arin
consistently appeared in films and TV
series since the 1960s specializing in
playing gregarious over-the-top and
self-deprecating figures an early figure
in the Improv movement that would shape
20th century comedy arim was among the
first members of Chicago's Second City
Theater part of the program's Broadway
debut in 1961 Arin would win a Tony
Award in 1963 for enter laughing Just 4
years after that he'd receive an Emmy
nomination for the Love Song of Barney
kinsky and an Oscar nomination for the
Cold War fast the Russians are coming
the Russians are coming the Oscars would
recognize Arin a few more times with
nods for 1968's the heart is a Lonely
Hunter and 2012's Argo he finally got a
win for 2006's Little Miss Sunshine for
the role of unhinged Grandpa Edwin in
between those career bookins Arin
starred in numerous and various well
received films including Wait Until Dark
Catch 22 last of the red hot lovers the
in-laws Edward Scissor Hands and grow
Point Blank according to a statement
from our kin Sons the actor died on June
29th at his ksb California home at 89
years old a definitive icon of the mid
20th century sexy French aesthetic that
spread through pop culture Jame Burkin
was a Singer model fashion figure and
actor from the 1960s onward born in
London and coming of age during the
city's swinging 60s Burkin relocated to
Paris where she found success as an
actor and singer particularly with her
partner French Superstar Serge gainsburg
whom she connected with on the set of
the movie slogan the envelope pushing
abundantly sensual 1969 single jiman was
banned in many places but it launched a
long musical career and made Burkin
hugely famous Burkin appeared in
numerous edgy 1960s and 1970s movies
including blowup wonder wall Laine and
Death on the Nile in 1984 the same year
AES introduced a highly coveted Burkin
bag which was inspired by the
Entertainer Burkin staring laat which
earned her the first of three Cesar
Award nominations followed by La fem
deari and Lael noaz Burkin performed
well into her 70s a stroke and broken
shoulder led to multiple canceled
engagements in 2023 on July 16th 2023
she died at her Paris home at age 76 a
major character actor lelia goldo had a
knack for collaborating with major URS
trained as a dancer with the Lester
Horton dancers goni switched to acting
in her late teens and studied with John
cassavetes in 1958 Shadows a lari
improvised film about then controversial
issues like interracial relationships he
cast galdoni as a black woman believed
by others to be white shadows garnered
galdoni a baa award nomination for most
promising newcomer soon after she
appeared in The Italian Job the day of
the Locust and Philip korman's 1978
remake of Invasion of the Body Snatchers
gon earned a second bath the nut for a
supporting role in Martin's G's Alice
doesn't live here anymore goni died on
July 22nd 2022 at the actor's fund home
in Englewood New Jersey she was 86 in
the 1970s Paul Rubin helped turn the Los
Angeles comedy Collective the
Groundlings into a workshop for top
level sketch comedians he part laid that
into 1980s the PeeWee Herman show a full
length production that sent up and
Darkly skewed oldfashioned Kitty TV
shows and he played the title role a
high voiced overly made up aescent
Manchild yeah if I could fly I'd be the
luckiest boy in the world the show was
such a hit that HBO taped it and brought
Peewee Mania National leading to the
1985 feature film peewee's big adventure
the 1988 sequel big top peewee and the
liveaction Emmy winning Saturday morning
classic peewee's playhouse in the 1980s
Ruben's almost always appeared in public
fully in character and costume as peewee
even hosting Saturday Night Live in that
guys after playhouse ended in 1990
rubben retired pee and delved into
primarily comedy character work popping
up briefly with memorable roles in film
and TV Ruben portrayed the Penguin's
father in Batman Returns a vampire
Lackey in Buffy the Vampire Slayer a
monstrous blue blood on 30 Rock and
spleen in Mystery Men in 2016 he revived
Peewee for the Netflix original peewee's
big holiday on July 31st 2023 a message
on Ruben's Instagram account revealed
that the actor and comedian died the
previous evening with a post that read
in part Paul bravely and privately
fought cancer for years with his
trademark tenacity and wit ruins was 70
while Angus Cloud attended the same
Oakland performing art school with his
eventual Euphoria co-al and DEA he was
working in a New York restaurant when
presented with the opportunity to
audition for the popular and influential
HBO team drama series Cloud quickly
became a pivotal member of the Euphoria
ensemble cast in its first two seasons
as emotionally complex drug dealer fesco
A supplier to Ru and love interest for
Lexi additionally Cloud made appearances
in the films North Hollywood and the
line popped up in several music videos
and was set to co-star in an anthology
film and a horror movie from the makers
of Scream 6 on the morning of July 31st
2023 the Oakland fire department
answered an emergency call where upon
they discovered Cloud's body Cloud's
family released a statement noting the
actor's history with mental health
issues and how his passing followed the
death of his father by Mia days it was
later confirmed that the actor had died
due to an accidental overdose Cloud was
25 years old a highly recognizable and
prolific actor Mark Margolis brought a
palpable and captivating intensity to
his roles which often called for
intimidating dangerous underworld
figures margolus broke out as Alberto
the shadow in the 1983 crime classic
Scarface for 5 years in the late 1990s
and early 2000s margolus portrayed
organized crime Lord Antonio Nappa on
HBO's Bleak prison drama Oz around the
same time margolus began a long
collaboration with filmmaker Darren
aronowski playing a math genius in pi
and roles in several of the director
other films but margolus is best known
for his portrayal of high-ranking drug
trafficking figure Hector salamona on
Breaking Bad and its prequel better
Coral the character couldn't speak
requiring margolus to do all his acting
with his face and a bell in 2012 the
performance earned Margolis and Emmy
Award number ation outstanding guest
actor in a drama series following a
brief period of sickness margolus died
at New York City's Mount Si Hospital the
actor was 83 Johnny Hardwick R appeared
in front of the camera so he's likely
not as recognizable for his face as he
is for his voice he portrayed an
effectual oblivious chainsm smoking
exterminator and conspiracy theorist
Dale Gribble in the Animated Series King
of the Hill for 13 years how is cutting
down on pollution a government plot Dale
open up your ass man they're trying to
control global warming when the show was
in pre-production King of the Hill
co-creator Greg Daniels attended a
comedy show case in Los Angeles after
hearing the Austin based Hardwick tell
some funny stories about his father he
hired the comic to be part of the
writing staff for the texus spoofing
cartoon then hard work auditioned to
play Dale and got the part his first
credited role on a filmography that
includes numerous independent projects
He also remained on the writing staff of
King of the Hill part of the team that
won a 1999 Emmy Award for outstanding
ing animated program someons to
Hardwick's Austin home on August 8th to
perform a welfare check police found the
body of the actor and writer Hardwick
was 64 alen Sim was a consistent
presence on network television for
decades in 1984 she started a 400 plus
episode run on Days of Our Lives as kopy
Jones Bradford a role that would Garner
her four Soap Opera Digest Awards and
two Daytime Emmy Award nominations sorin
paray that into a supporting role on the
1987 sitcom duet one of the first ever
[__] shows and it's spin-off open house
the actor also hosted the America's
Funniest Home Video spin-off America's
funniest people in addition to winning a
Peabody Award for her work producing the
2010 documentary boo sain's grandest
achievement is originating and defining
the role of Harley Quinn in numerous
animated DC Comics projects beginning
with Batman the Animated Series in 1992
sain voiced the character in 12 projects
total across video TV and the internet
sain's death was announced on August
26th 2023 she was
67 while not primarily an actor Bob
Barker was an Entertainer television
star and household name while hosting
the Bob Baraka show in 1950 Los Angeles
he was plucked to host a television
version of the popular radio game show
Truth or Consequences a gig Barker held
for 18 years his follow-up project
lasted even longer and made him a legend
in 1972 Barker hosted the first of more
than 6,500 epod episodes of the prices
right he retired in 2007 collecting 19
Emy Awards along the way thanks to the
prices right the many televised pageants
he hosted and his animal rights activism
Barker became famous for being Bob
Barker help control the pet population
have your pets F neutered he even played
fictionalized heightened versions of
himself from time to time Bara
contributed cameos to Futurama Yes dear
How I Met Your Mother The Nanny and the
most famously Happy Gilmore in the 1996
comedy he memorably and thoroughly
pummels Adam Sandler's character on a
golf course Barker's publicist announced
on August 26th 2023 that the game show
host had died Barker was
99 initially a stage act dur in his
native South Korea B and heong moved
into voice acting on television in the
1960s it eventually become a prolific
often cast award-winning character actor
on popular and notable Korean TV shows
including the First Republic and white
power however bian would find
International recognition when he began
a series of collaborations with
acclaimed filmmaker bong junho he
portrayed Sergeant kui bong in 2003's
memories of murder and Park Family
patriarch he bong in 2006's box office
smash the host BM was most likely best
known for his role as the lead
character's grandfather in bong's Canan
film festival and Netflix hit Fantasy
oga on September 18th 2023 beon died
After experiencing medical issues
related to recurrence of diagnosed and
treated pancreatic cancer Bean was 81
years old after landing breakthrough
roles in 60s Classics a great escape and
the greatest story ever told David
McCallum enjoyed a long and illustrious
career book ended by playing major
characters on two irid defining TV
series about intelligence agents in the
James Bond influence 1964 spy series The
Man from Uncle mallum played Elite
secret agent Ilia kurakin who along with
Robert vaugh solo waged weekly War
around the world against the nefarious
thrush mullum would reprise the roled in
multiple TV projects along with the big
screen Uncle off shoots once byy too
many one of our spies is missing and the
karate Killers then in 2003 mallum
co-starred an NCIS as Dr Donald ducky
malard a veteran criminal profiler and
provider of low-key comic relief mallum
died of natural causes in New York City
on September 25th
2023 he was 90 years old one of the most
acclaimed and prolific actors of his
generation Michael Gambon began his long
cinematic career in 1965 having a small
role in lence Olivier's adaptation of
Shakespeare's aell Gambon broke out
internationally in the 80s with a 1985
romance turtle diary and the 1986 TV
series The Singing detective that show
won Gambon his first bafter TV award a
prize he also took home for wives and
daughters longitude and perfect
strangers in the US Gambon was nominated
for Emmys for his work in path to war
and 2009's Emma also a star of the
British stage and winner of three Olivia
Awards gamban is probably best known for
his post 2000 work such as voicing uncle
pastuzo in the Paddington films and the
villainous Bean in Fantastic Mr Fox
after the late Richard Harris died in
2002 gambal was picked to play the part
of Hogwarts head Master Albert
Dumbledore in the Harry Potter series
guiding and assisting the boy who lived
over the course of six films on
September 28th 202 3 gamon's family
announced that the actor had died after
Contracting pneumonia Gambon was 82
years
old Al Brown didn't start acting
professionally until the 1990s when he
was in his mid-50s before he was a
performer he served in the US Air Force
and put in two tours of Duty during the
Vietnam war his acting career ultimately
consisted of small but memorable roles
usually uninformed professionals or
authority figures Brown played officers
in several TV shows and movies and his
first role was as a sheriff's deputy in
a 1995 episode of homicide life on the
street and when that show's Creator
David Simon launched the wire on HBO in
2002 the actor landed the role of
Baltimore Police Commissioner Stan vek
Brownwood recur across all six seasons
of the acclaimed drama at the age of 83
Brown passed away from Alzheimer's
disease on January 13th
2023 Canadian character actor George R
Robertson already had nearly two decades
of acting experience before he landed
his signature role in 1984 Henry Hurst
the nefarious yet supportive chief of
police in Police Academy Robertson
repris a role in five sequels and the
police academy TV series this role
turned out to be the middle of his long
and varied career he regularly played
strong authoritative characters and was
frequently cast as politicians both real
and imagined including the president in
senior trip Senator Barry Goldwater in
the Reagans and vice President Dick
Cheney in the path to 9/11 according to
Legacy Robertson died on January 29th
2023 in Toronto he was
89 entering the entertainment industry
in 2006 Cody Longo became something of a
Teen Idol in Rapid succession he starred
in two JoJo videos the movie ball don't
lie and the 2009 remake of Fame in young
adulthood Longo landed a recurring part
on Days of Our Lives as Nikki alamain
and he also stood out on Hollywood
Heights as Rockstar Eddie Duran however
Longo's career virtually crat following
a 2020 domestic assault arrest then in
2021 Longo was charged with the sexual
assault of a minor which led him to
plead guilty to a misdemeanor assault
charge on February 8th 20123 police in
Austin Texas provided a wellness check
requested by Longo's wife they found the
actor dead in his bedroom an autopsy
determines that the cause of death was
chronic drinking Longo was 34 years old
Gerald Castillo was likely known to most
modern audiences for a couple of
recurring roles on very successful 1980s
daytime television programs but he
started out as a stage performer in
Chicago and then a number of nationally
touring Productions on the advice of
co-star Sherman Hemsley Castillo headed
to Hollywood and landed several small
roles on television and film from 1992
to 1994 he earned particular distinction
for playing judge Davis Wagner on the
ABC soap opera General Hospital right
around the same time he portrayed major
Slater a hard-nosed military dad unsaved
by the Bell Castillo retired from
performing in 2012 and moved to Houston
where he died at home on May 4th 2023
the actor was 90 years old Jaclyn Zan is
known primarily for one role which he
played for more than 45 years it
elevated her to Icon status with in a
fiercely beloved television genre from
1977 until 20223 Zeman portrayed nurse
Bobby Spencer on ABC's daytime soap
General Hospital out lasting dozens of
co-stars and figuring in hundreds of
story lines Zeman appeared in nearly 900
episodes of the serial drama strongly
associated with both her character and
soaps in general Zeman also enjoyed
cameos and soap spoofing projects and
had a continuing role of sfia Madison on
the peacock cereal the bay for her work
on General Hospital Zan was nominated
for four daytime Emy Awards along with
one nod for the Bay on May 10th 2023
General Hospital executive producer
Frank Valentini announced Sean's death
on Twitter Zan's family told ABC news
that the actor died from complications
of cancer the soap star was 70 years old
Bobby and I may have had our
differences she loved her family and I
always respected her so much for that at
8 years old Canadian actor Samantha
Weinstein entered the TV industry with a
guest part on the long running comedy
the red green Shir she would go on to
work steadily in liveaction Productions
and as a voice actor in numerous
animated series some of Weinstein's most
notable film work includes Jesus Henry
Christ the Seline Dion biopic Seline The
Rocker and the 2013 remake of Carrie
where she played one of the bullies in
2021 Weinstein was diagnosed with a rare
and aggressive variety of ovarian cancer
following more than 2 years of treatment
the actor died on May 14th 2023 at the
age of 28 all male vocal quartets
dominated pop music in the early 1950s
Ed Ames was a major part of this wave as
a member of the am Brothers the group
topped the charts with quite a few hits
after Rock took over by the decade's end
Ames moved into Stage acting among the
Productions he starred in was I do I do
which generated a solo hit single called
who will answer however history Buffs
and fans of 1960s TV will probably
recognize ases for his turn on Daniel
Boon from 1964 to to 1970 he played
Mingo an Oxford educated Cherokee guide
interestingly while promoting the show
Ames featured in one of the most famous
bits on The Tonight Show in
demonstrating how to throw a hatchet he
comically nailed a cowboy silhouette in
the groin eliciting hows of laughter
from the audience and host Johnny
Carson am's spouse Gian Ames told the
media that the actor and singer died on
May 21st 2023
from complications of Alzheimer's he was
95 years old an army veteran and
prolific stage actor Lou palter was
nearly 40 years old before he booked his
first national TV role on a 1967 episode
of run for your life in 1971 he began a
four decade run as an acting teacher at
Cal arts in Santa Clarita California and
he also ran workshops around the US and
in Europe poter also worked steadily as
a guest performer on a variety of
network TV series the actor's most
significant roles were in the 1981 legal
drama first Monday in October and as
real life Tycoon Isador Strauss in
1997's Titanic the actor's daughter
reported that polter died on May 21st
2023 at his Los Angeles home he was
94 with a string of memorable roles in
1970s cult classics Marlene Clark left a
big impression on audiences following
her performance and the made for TV
movie Lost flight opposite then husband
Billy D Williams Clark portrayed a
likely werewolf in the Beast must die a
reptilian in Knight of the Cobra woman a
victim in beware the blob and a
secretary in Bruce Le's end of the
Dragon Clark's most enjoying films were
the 1973 canit ganja and Hess and 1975's
switchblade sisters Clark also gained
fam as Janet Lawson fiance to Fred sson
Son Lamont on the immensely popular 1970
sitcom Samford and sun in the 1980s and
1990s Clark moved into AC parttime to
run her own upscale clothing boutique
and manage a restaurant Clark died at
her Los Angeles home on May 18th 2023 no
cause of death was immediately provided
she was 85 years old Francis Ford Copa
frequently cast Frederick forest in his
movies in 1974 he portrayed Mark in the
conversation and 8 years later he landed
a romantic lead in one from the heart in
1979's Apocalypse Now Forest gave a
riveting performance as Jay Chef Hicks
who suffers a breakdown in the Vietnam
war that same year Forest received
Golden Globe and Academy Award
nominations for his role in the Rose as
an awal army Sergeant and limosine
driver who provides guidance for the
titular Rockstar character in the 80s
and '90s Forest would pop up in The
Lonesome Dove miniseries originate the
role of Captain Jenkins on Fox's early
hit 21 Jump Street and appear in
numerous other films Faris friend Barry
Primus told The Hollywood Reporter that
the actor had a lengthy illness before
dying at his to Santa Monica California
home on June 23rd 2023 at 86 years old a
prolific actor of stage and screen with
a decade spanning career Ron C fuss
Jones earned Fame and acclaim for a
string of high-profile roles in popular
TV series Jones landed a recurring role
on this is us as William Hill the dying
biological father of adopted triplet
Randall the part Garner Jones for
outstanding guest actor in a drama
nominations at the Emmys an award he won
twice he also portrayed shrie Scoville
on the murder mystery truth be told and
Renegade hacker Romero on Mr Robot Jones
popped up frequently on crime shows and
TV comedies he also had a number of
supporting roles in films over the years
the actor's representative reported that
Jones's death was related to a long-term
pulmonary issue he was 66 years
old before becoming a TV personality
Dick Butkus was among the most dominant
linebackers of his era in the NFL from
1965 to 196 73 the Pro Football Hall of
Fame in Duck D set League records in
recovered fumbles and was named
Defensive Player of the Year twice he
was later named to the NFL's 100th
anniversary Squad but C pared His Image
as a tough guy on the field into an
acting career following an appearance as
himself in the 1971 football based TV
movie Brian song while still an active
player buckus booked guest spots on
numerous action shows in the mid 1980s
buck card on the quickly cancelled
helicopter Centric police show Thunder
and was cast in a long running Sports
Focus campaign for Miller Light beer
tomorrow we're going to try our hand at
Water Polo yeah I sure hope those horses
can swim me too he's probably best known
to younger viewers for his roles on
sitcoms for kids such as a former
football player who ran a Hangout
restaurant on My Two Dads and a high
school basketball coach on hangtime
buckus his family announced on social
media that he had died in his sleep on
October 5th 2023 he was 80 years old for
three seasons starting in 1965 Lost in
Space was one of the first hit science
fiction TV series it followed the cosmos
wandering Robinson family whose ship was
piloted by the Brash major Don West he
was portrayed by Mark Godard already
familiar to television viewers for his
roles on action shows like the
detectives and Johnny Ringo a starring
role on the short Liv sitcom many happy
returns and appearances on Perry Mason
and The Beverly Hillbillies as the
decades marched on Godard took on
supporting roles in movies and guest
starred on sitcoms soaps and crime
dramas he enjoyed a prominent cameo in
the 1998 big screen adaptation of Lost
in Space where Goddard portrayed a
general Goddard died from pulmonary
fibrosis on October 10th 2023 in Ham
Massachusetts he was 87 years old
portraying an iconic comic book
character as an opportunity afforded to
few actors and it's even rarer to
originate the character's onscreen
depiction Phyllis Co was a very first
first actor to play Lois Lane both in
film and on television after performing
in voeville and Uso shows and scoring
bit Parts in a few movies coat landed
the part of Superman's love interests
and Clark Kent's colleague in the 1951
movie Superman and the mle men in 1952
the film was adapted into the syndicated
television show Adventures of Superman
coats portrayed Lois Lane in the first
season and would go on to act in more
than 100 movies and TV series she
appeared in one episode of Lois and
Clark the new Adventures of Superman as
Lois Lane's mother coat died at the
motion picture in television country
house and Hospital in Southern
California on October 11th 2023 of
natural causes she was
96 Rosetta Jacobs landed a contract with
Universal Studios while still in high
school by 1950 she was throwing opposite
Ronald Reagan in Louisa under the name
Piper Lori Lori would earn her first
Academy Award nomination by 1962 for her
role in the pool drama The Hustler for
the next decade or so she moved away
from film to perform on Broadway her
return to film proved fruitful Lori
earned more Oscar recognition for Carrie
and children of Alessa God she also saw
a lot of success on TV ultimately
gaining nine Emmy nominations for
Productions including The Thorn Birds
and Saint elsewhere she enjoyed a
particularly major comeback in David
Lynch's surre real mystery series Twin
Peaks receiving two of her Emy
nominations for her role as Catherine
Martel everything smells like fish
around here Lori appeared on screen in
2018 in an episode of maiva and the film
white boy Rick according to her
representative Lori died in Los Angeles
on October 14th 2023 after a lengthy
period of illness she was
91 Suzanne Summers launched her career
with a memorable bit role as an
anonymous woman in a white Thunderbird
in George Lucas's 1973 smash American
Graffiti 4 years later she landed the
role that made her famous the comically
dumb Chrissy snow one of three three
roommates on the ryal ABC hit 3's
company one more word and I will stick
this umbrella up your pants and open it
slowly written out of the show after
asking for a salary increase Summers
resurfaced on the mid1 1980s syndicated
sitcom she's the Sheriff before landing
another lead role on Long running ABC
comedy step by step but throughout the
1990s summons was more visible for a
different TV gig being the onair pitch
person for the Thigh Master exercise
Gadget Summers and her husband the
manager and haml ultimately bought the
rights to the Thigh Master an Endeavor
that earned them an estimated $300
million according to a statement summer
publicists shared with people the actor
and entrepreneur was diagnosed with
breast cancer more than 20 years ago on
October 15th 20123 a day before her 77th
birthday Summers died at home surrounded
by Family Bert young acted in more than
160 films and TV shows most prominently
gritty 1970s and 1980s crime Classics
like Chinatown Once Upon a Time in
America and the pope of Greenwich
Village he often played toughs and
brutes using the edge he developed in
the US Marines and his 17 and one record
as a professional boxer his experience
with the sport inform formed his
signature and most acclaimed role that
of cornerman Butcher and Matchmaker py
in 1976's Rocky among the film's many
Academy Award nominations young received
a nod for best actor in a supporting
role after writing and starring in the
Jazz drama Uncle Joe Shannon in 1978
young propris role of Paulie in four
more Rocky films and appeared on
episodes of Miami Vice Lauren order The
Equalizer and Russian Dal Young's
daughter told the New York Times that
her father died on October 8th 20123 no
cause of death was given young was 83
years old Richard rre was a working
actor for more than 50 years appearing
in the film moving on and the TV series
cherish the day and family reunion in
2022 but he was forever associated with
and Best Loved for his very first movie
role the title character in 1971's shaft
in what would be remembered as a
quintessential entry in the black
exploitation genre Round Tree portrayed
one of the coolest detectives around my
name is John sha freeze round Tre was
also in the sequels Sha's big score and
shaft in Africa a shaft TV series and a
2 and 2019 franchise reboot roundt tree
a Golden Globe winner for most promising
newcomer for shaft also popped up in
epics comedies The Landmark miniseries
Roots and more recently TV projects such
as Desperate Housewives and Being Mary
Jane Round Tree died from pancreatic
cancer on October 24th 2023 the actor
was 81 when Richard M made a simple
choice for a part in a b movie it helped
him land the signature role one had play
for 8 years his shaved head in the
Sci-Fi B movie movie Metal Storm the
destruction of Jared sin got the
attention of nightt producers who cast
him as baith bll Shannon writers
reimagine the character with Maul's
input as a gentle giant and sweet
goofball abandoning their idea of making
him a tough guy
okay before and after night court mul
appeared on TV a lot most recently guest
starring as The Drifter on Nickelodeon's
100 Deeds for Eddie McDow he also voiced
characters in American pop and Mighty
Max as well as multip animated Batman
projects as Harvey Dent AKA Twoface ma
died at home in Big Bear Lake California
on October 26th at the age of 80 in the
late 1980s and early 1990s Matthew Perry
was almost constantly guest staring on
television shows showing up on sitcoms
including Charles in Charge silver
spoons and empty nest he even starred on
one of the first ever [__] shows boys
will be boys and guested for a dramatic
arc on growing paint of course in 199 4
Perry became one of the most famous
people in the world as part of the IRA
definitive comedy friends he played the
funny quippy commitment to verse Chan Le
Bing a character he would inhabit for a
decade that would earn him an Emmy
nomination back then I uh used humor as
a defense mechanism thank God I don't do
that anymore after friends wrapped in
2004 Perry continued to appear on TV in
high profile projects including the West
Wing Studio 60 on the Sunset Strip go on
a remake of The Odd Couple and Mr
Sunshine a cynical sitcom he co-created
very last appeared on screen in 2017 not
counting 2021s Friends reunion but he
generated a lot of media attention in
2022 for his tell all Memoir friends
lovers and the big terrible thing which
detailed his long and harrowing history
of Addiction on October 28th 20123 TMZ
reported that authorities responded to a
cardiac arrest emergency at a Los
Angeles home where Perry was discovered
dead in his hot tub in December 2023 the
Los Angeles County Medical examiner's
Office determines that Perry had died
due to the acute effects of ketamine
which led to cardiovascular
overstimulation and respiratory
depression officials also listed
drowning coronary artery disease and
buprenorphine a prescription drug used
as a heroin replacement as contributing
factors Perry was
54 Tyler Christopher's very first role
brought him Fame and kept him working
for 20 years Nicholas cassadine a
character later revealed to be a prince
on General Hospital he portrayed
Nicholas for more than 1,000 episodes
after departing General Hospital
Christopher moved to Days of Our Lives
from 2018 to 2019 playing Stefan deera a
role that earned him a Daytime Emmy
Award nomination Christopher also made
time for other work particularly a
string of natural disaster B movies
including super volcano 20.0 Mega quake
and ice storm Christopher's General
Hospital co-star Maurice Bernard
announced the actor's death on Instagram
on October 31st
20123 he was 50 years old a chief
instructor at one of Chu Norris's karate
acmy and a ninth degree black belt Pat E
Johnson was perhaps most famous for
teaching martial arts to the actors of
The Karate Kid as a nod to his influence
on the movies veracity Johnson was cast
as a karate tournament referee in part
one they had built this Barn because
they were in this pain together in this
discipline oh oh you know it's like
having a mean teacher a mean coach he
serves as the official martial arts
supervisor and trainer in both sequels
The Karate Kid Part 2 and the Karate Kid
Part 3 while also apprising his role as
a referee in those films he then
organized a karate for the 1994
franchise reboot The Next Karate Kid
Johnson also appeared in ' 70s martial
arts movies like Enter the Dragon and a
force of one after this period he put
his skills to the test as both both a
stunted coordinator and stun performer
in action heavy films of the 1990s
including Mortal Kombat Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and the original Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles on November 5th
2023 Johnson's niece broke the news that
the actor and a martial artist had died
at home in Los Angeles at the age of
84 Suzanne Shepard spent decades helping
actors reach their full potential on
both their stage and screen when not
directing plays across the United States
or perform pering her own roles shepher
ran and taught at her acting studio in
New York City shepher didn't move in
front of the camera until she was in her
50s Landing a role in the 1988 Julia
Roberts romantic comedy Mystic Pizza she
quickly signed up for supporting roles
in Uncle Burke and working girl before
appearing in the mob drama Good Fellas
soon after Shepherd appeared as the
mother of camela soprano on The Sopranos
apart from those Milestone roles shepher
appeared in numerous other films and TV
guest roles the actor teacher and
director died on November 17th 2023 at
her New York City Home according to her
agent she was 89 years old an acclaimed
and highly trained actor in the British
tradition with well over 100 screen
credits and a long theatrical resume Jos
akam was named a commander of the
British Empire in 2001 for his
contributions to the Arts but to
Contemporary American audiences he's
likely best known for scene stealing
roles as over-the-top fish villain in 19
1991's Bill and Ted's Bogus Journey
akland played the nasty time traveling
villain the nalos and in 1989's Lethal
Weapon 2 he played the entitled Arjen
red who gets away with his Crimes by
shouting diplomatic Community akland
also played Russian Ambassador Andre
lysenko in The Hunt for Red October and
contributed to k19 the Widowmaker and
water ship down his two most critically
recognized works are white mischief and
the baa nominated first first and last
akan died on November 19th 2023 he was
95 in the 1980s and Beyond Francis
stagen became the go-to actor to play
the mothers of wellestablished TV
characters she had a recurring Emmy
Award nominated role on Cheers as Esther
claven the seldom pleased mother of
doting mama's boy Cliff Clavin and
another on ER as millison Carter the
grand mother of Dr John Carter on Sex in
the City she received another Emmy
nomination for her work as bun McDougall
Charlotte's uptight mother-in-law the
storyed actor landed 70 plus supporting
roles on TV and in movies including the
Stephen King adaptations the mist and
misery she wasn't just a star on screen
though she made plenty of appearances on
stage the two-time Tony award winner
appeared in major Broadway Productions
of the skin of our teeth at doll's house
and long day journey in tonight Stern
Hagen's son actor John Carin announced
on Instagram that his mother died on
November 27th 2023 she was 6 weeks away
from turning 94 years old as an actor
with Down Syndrome who appeared
regularly on screen Andrea F Friedman
advocated for and demonstrated the
importance of inclusion and
representation in the early 1990s she
appeared on 14 episodes of the ABC
family drama life goes on as Amanda
Swanson romantic partner of regular
character corki thater she went on to
earn guest roles on many TV series
including Baywatch ER Laur and Order
Special Victims Unit and Family Guy
Friedman was also the focus of the
documentary a possible dream the Andrea
Friedman Story the actor last appeared
on screen in the 2019 holiday movie
Carol of the Bells Friedman died on
December 3rd 2023 from complications of
Alzheimer's disease the actor was 53
years old already a huge TV star in Teen
Idol thanks to a 5-year run on the TV
soap opera Payton place in the 1960s
Ryan O'Neal all shot to the top of the
movie star alist in the 1970s by
headlining box office smashes and
critical Darlings alike he played cocky
Ivy Liga Oliver in the tragic romantic
drama Love Story the top grossing film
of 1970 the role earned O'Neal and Oscar
nomination for best actor he followed
that up with a starring role opposite
Barbara stren in the hit 1972 fast whats
up dark and depart as a con artist in
Paper Moon alongside his daughter Tatum
O'Neal in Stanley rubrics Oscar
nominated 1975 period piece Barry Linden
O'Neal portrayed the Title Character
this winning streak continued as O'Neal
starden while received mainstream Fair
sometimes working with his on again off
again romantic partner of many years far
foret O'Neal's final role was Shifty Max
Keenan across two dozen episodes of
bones more than 20 years after a chronic
leukemia diagnosis and a decade after
developing prostate cancer anneal died
in Santa Monica on December 8th 2023 he
was
82 Wy acclaimed as one of the most
talented and craft devoted actors of his
generation Andre Brower dazzled
audiences with major roles over the
course of the past 30 years following
breakout roles in the Civil War epic
glory and a series of cojac TV movies in
1989 Brower a graduate of Stanford and
juliard portrayed Baltimore homicide
detective Frank pembleton on the
acclaimed NBC police drama homicide life
on the street that role landed Brower
his first Emmy Award for outstanding
lead actor in a drama series after his
Emmy nomination for the short-lived
medical drama Gideon's Crossing brow won
again for the limited series Thief
before demonstrating his range and
picking up more nominations by starring
on The dram men of a certain age when
that series concluded brow looned large
over the wacky police comedy Brooklyn 99
in which he portrayed the hilariously de
pan Captain Raymond
ha these have been the best
years of my career according to brow's
publicist the actor died on December
11th 2023 it was later revealed that his
cause of death was lung cancer Brower
was 61 years old character actor James
mcaffrey scored more than 100 acting
roles over the course of his career
which began with a bit part in the 1987
sex comedy New York's finest after a few
more supporting gigs mcaffrey landed a
prominent supporting role as Joe Aster
in the '90s syndicated action drama
it wasn't on television where mcaffrey
would find his signature role though the
actor took on the role of the Rogue
Vengeance minded detective max pain in
the video game of the same name
maccaffrey went on to apprise his voice
performance in max pay 2 the fall of Max
pay and max pain 3 while continuing to
appear in Indie movies and on television
series notably he starred as ghostly New
York City firefighter Jimmy Keefe on
effect's rescue me Ryan Huntley on ABC's
Prime Time soap Revenge and Danton
Phillips on Netflix's Spike Lee
adaptation she's got to have it on
December 17th 2023 mcaffrey who had been
diagnosed with M LMA a form of cancer
that affects the blood died at home in
largman New York the actor was
65 Tamar deo's Reyes starred in projects
ranging from soap operas to video games
in a career of more than three decades
he appeared in 287 episodes of the soap
One Life to Live in the role of Antonio
Vega in his recent roles he had a season
long Arc as a demon in the Sleepy Hollow
TV show played a coach on the CWS
allamerican and was featured in several
episodes of the rookie if you're a gamer
you'll best recognize him as the main
villain of the Blockbuster video game
Call of Duty Black Ops 2 a role which he
repr reprised in Black Ops 4 and Call of
Duty Vanguard Reyes passed away on
Christmas Eve 2023 dying from cancer at
the age of
56 apart from Plenty of theatrical roles
and appearances un popular British
television series spanning more than 50
years Richard Franklin is likely most
familiar to viewers in the US and the UK
from his work in two science fiction
franchises after studying at the Royal
Academy of dramatic art Franklin made
his mark As Captain Mike Yates on Doctor
Who in the 1970s Franklin popped up on
42 episodes of the series alongside the
third doctor and even after he left the
show he stayed a hoan for life he
reprised the character in audio works
and wrote the doctor who spin-off novel
The Killing Stone after stins on several
more British shows Franklin was cast as
Death Star engineer Z argon in Rogue one
a Star Wars story Franklin died sometime
in the early morning of December 25th
2023 following a lengthy period of
illness he was 87 years old the Smothers
Brothers was a very unique Duo act
featuring siblings Dick and Tom Smothers
as a blended rapid fire stage patter
with folk music that evolved from
lighthearted to politically volatile Tom
Smothers traditionally the sillier
figure compared to Dick straight man
Persona was the main voice behind the
shift to anti- Vietnam War subject
matter and his incendiary sketches ended
up getting the very popular the Smothers
Brothers comedy hour canor in 1969 the
show in question was uh considered by
CBS to be in bad taste in general first
and foremost a musical comedian Tom
Smothers was also an actor both with and
without his brother before their variety
show hit the air Wes the pair start in
the 1965 to 1966 sitcom the Smothers
Brothers show Tom played a bumbling
ghost that was Haunting his nerdy
brother he became a near constant TV
presence after that with appearances in
numerous shows including the loveboat
and The Simpsons Smothers also enjoyed
roles in comedy films like the informant
and the cold classic horror parody
pandemonium Smothers died at home on
December 26th 2023 from causes related
to a cancer diagnosis he was a 86 in the
English-speaking world the Sunan is
probably most recognizable for its role
as Park dong geek the well-off owner of
the palacial home in 2019s parasite the
Korean drama broke out in the west and
won the Academy Award for best picture
the first foreign language film to do so
in the ceremony's history apart from
parasite Lee was a main stay of the
Korean film and television industry with
a career going back two decades
primarily working in episodic television
Lee co-starred on series including
Pastor my mister behind the White Tower
golden time Miss Korea Diary of a
prosecutor payback and Dr Brain the
latter nabbed Le a nomination for best
performance by an actor at the
international Emmy Awards in 2022 in his
personal life things were more
complicated Lee was thoroughly
questioned multiple times in a 2023
South Korean government drug busting
campaign and the actor claimed he was
coerced into ingesting illegal
substances as part of a blackmail plot
after a missing person's report was
filed on his behalf Lee was discovered
dead in his car on December 27th with
authorities initially rolling the cause
of death to be suicide the actor was
48 Tom wilon had already appeared in
four dozen projects most he produced in
his home country of the United Kingdom
before he broke out on a global scale in
1997 that year he played both the
villainous marquest of Queensbury in the
Oscar wild biopic wild and Gerald an
unemployed middle-aged man who for
exotic dancing in the full monty the
latter comedy won Wilkinson a bafter for
best performance by an actor in a
supporting role and the film was
nominated for best picture at the
Academy Awards from that point Wilkinson
went on to appear in a long string of
critically acclaimed and popular films
in 1998's best picture winning
Shakespeare in Love he co-starred as
theatrical financer Hugh fennyman and 3
years later he earned a best actor Oscar
nomination for the Indie drama in the
bedroom alongside major roles in Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind the
Patriot Valkyrie The Best Exotic
maragold hotel and Batman Begins
Wilkinson was again nominated for an
Oscar for Michael Clayton in which he
portrayed a lawyer in the midst of a
manic episode I am Shiva the god of
death on the small screen Wilkinson was
often sort out to portray complicated
historical figures he won an Emmy for
his work as Benjamin Franklin in HBO's
John Adams and he received a nomination
for playing Joseph Kennedy in real is
the kennedies Wilkinson died abruptly at
his home with family present on December
30th 2023 the actor was 75 unfortunately
we couldn't include everyone in our full
list other actors who passed away in
2023 included George P Wilbur Paul Grant
George Maharis Mike payre Inus Swenson
Darren Kent Evan Ellingson Benjamin
Zephaniah Ellen Holly David mcnight
Camden toy mike nbal David
Soul
[Music]